have you ever wondered what it would
feel like to buy your dream house in
cash or maybe you have throwing tens of
thousands of dollars every year at it to
finally get rid of your mortgage payment
most people hate paying rent or a
mortgage but at the same time rich
people love to pay rent or mortgage they
flat-out refused to buy a house in cash
despite being able to comfortably afford
it so why do rich people refuse to buy a
house in cash well you can get mortgages
with just 3.5% down with a fixed
interest rate of well under 4% meanwhile
if you were looking at buying a
commercial property you're looking at a
down payment of at least 15% but to get
a good interest rate realistically this
would cost around 25 to 35 percent and
you still be looking at an interest rate
of at least 5% as you can see not only
do you have to put down more to get a
commercial property but you also have to
pay a higher interest rate let's say we
have a multi-millionaire real estate
investor he has a monthly bills
emergency fund and all that taken care
of after all this he has 10 million
dollars to invest he wants to buy a 5
million dollar property and spend the
rest of his money on the down payment of
a commercial apartment building now as
our guy is very experienced in this
field he knows that he has to put down
30% on a commercial property in order to
get an interest rate and mortgage
payment that is low enough the cash flow
or profit after all expenses $200 per
unit in his apartment complex this guy
also loves to invest in c-class
neighborhoods or middle-of-the-road
Average places where each apartment unit
costs approximately a hundred thousand
before we move on let me actually show
you that this is not a very good
investment in the first place breaking
it down into each a puttan unit we can
see that this guy is putting down
$33,000 for each unit and getting $200
at month or $24 a year which means is
cash on cash return or the money he gets
back every dollar he spends is only
seven point two seven percent this man
could have
just invested in the S&P 500 which has
consistently provided a 7% return per
year on average over the past century of
course he wouldn't get realized their
appreciation or tax benefits by doing
this but he does avoid the headache of
managing a commercial property as a
result the 7% that our Investor guy's
getting is actually quite mediocre but
this really illustrates the
profitability of not buy your house in
cash so going back to our guy he could
buy the house for the full 5 million and
spend the other 5 million as a
downpayment on the commercial property
at 33 percent down he could get a 15
million dollar apartment complex with
150 units assuming $100,000 per unit at
a profit of two hundredth power unit our
guy will be making thirty thousand
dollars a month or 360 dollars a year
off of this building but what if our guy
purchased his house on his loan he could
go as low as 3.5% down but let's just
say he puts 20% down as this is the
minimum of the Void private mortgage
insurance
meaning that he would have nine million
dollars to invest in a commercial
property at 33 percent down meaning that
he can now purchase a twenty seven
million dollar apartment complex as
opposed to a fifteen million dollar
complex at the same $100,000 a unit and
two dollars a unit per month in cash
flow this building's 270 units would
generate 54,000 dollars a month as
opposed to $30,000 a month but of course
on the house that he just purchased he
would have to pay principal and interest
which had an interest rate of 4% which
our guy would probably beat he would
have to pay $19,000 a month our guy
would be able to profit about $5,000 a
month or $60,000 a year but really this
might as well be zero as her guy doesn't
really care about this he's in it for
the long term game in 30 years when he
pays off both this house and this
commercial property take a look how much
more money he would have first of all
let's say both these properties
appreciate at just 3% at this rate the
properties aren't gaining any real value
they're simply keeping up with inflation
what the five million are how
in cash and fifty million dollar
apartment complex our guy would be worth
48 million dollars at the end but our
guy with the five million house and
twenty seven million dollar property
will be worth seventy seven million
dollars at the end this means that by
simply not buying his house in cash he
made a million dollars a year in
non-taxable net worth and this only gets
better with the time as exponential
growth favors a larger principal value
on top of this what about the extra cash
flow from the extra 100 years which he
now fully owns and what if he actually
invested in a commercial property with a
more than ten percent cash on cash
return of course you can contest my
numbers all day in the comment section
but this has nothing to do with the
potential of a commercial building and
everything to do with simply beating out
the 4% mortgage rate of a person's house
or present mortgage rate which you can
get on a house is basically unbeatable
with any other type of loan and this is
why rich people put little down keeping
us little money as they can in the house
they live but this doesn't just apply to
rich people every homeowner can take
advantage of this don't start off by
taking money out of your house however
if you have been investing for a few
years and are confident you can beat a
4% return on investment definitely
consider taking money out of your house
this could be a simple cash out
refinance or a home equity line of
credit of course if it gives you peace
of mind to own your own house then don't
do it as it is simply not worth it but
that's why many rich people refuse to
buy houses in cash if you thought this
video explained rich people's aversion
to owning the house they live in then
make sure to drop a like and consider
subscribing you flexi more questions
just like this one logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one